what's up everyone Matthew and Sina here
and in today's episode I had a chance to
interview Nydia Diaz on her beautiful
work and the amazing process behind it
Nidhi has a freelance art director and
designer based out of porto portugal and
as an art director she leads teams of
designers to determine the visual
direction of her projects her work is
focused mainly on designing style frames
for motion design projects and for those
of you who don't know style frames are
simply rendered 2d or 3d still images
that determine the look of a motion
design piece now let's get into it by
looking at her project for Microsoft
Office 365
what was this project and what was the
goal of this project so Microsoft I'm
last year I was working at Central in
Toronto and Microsoft approaches to help
them share Microsoft Lumia 65 so
everyone is his office
but like the majority of populations his
office and they were going for this
redesign so Microsoft has has been in
the last years having this thing called
fluent design just kind of see much like
Google material where they create their
own like trying to really make
everything that make sure that
everything looks the same so they were
doing that too the whole word office
anything within the office team not only
the icons but also like inside the app
like small icons they're the height of
the things are and some of that so they
wanted to make a video that showcase hey
we are revamping office but it's still
the same as you know it so if you've
been using for a lot of years and you're
a power user you still have all those
functions so we just kind of tie things
up a little bit so they wanted to have
like they come to us and ask us for like
a few different options in terms of
treatments and we end up combining like
the live-action CD we wanted to give the
human touch we didn't want to be just
like here's all the UI I guess then we
could just record a video of like here's
how you use office so we wanted to be
like going between like live-action and
then have like the moments that we'd
show the new logos for word and all the
stuff
designing and then all the
functionalities that were new like
obviously they wanted to compete with
Google so they have like collaboration
now and stuff I mean so it's a lot of
that was was one of the main purpose you
know as well like the great like this
was very important that it came from the
design minds set then just here just
word and we're just putting whatever
buttons is there so here was going from
like telling a story of how Microsoft
was evolving but as well as showing all
the features that would make it relevant
and I just want to highlight that I just
I think that's super smart so you know
doesn't matter if it's live action or 2d
or 3d here you're looking for very
consistent things to loop them all
together because it's all these very
tiny details that really add up and I
think it's very easy to overlook these
things but if you're very consistent
about you know color coding or whatever
the design system is across the board
then it becomes a very cohesive and a
very tight piece yeah we tried I mean
it's it's Microsoft as well right so
they all have their brand guidelines and
so for that so that was something like
that I had to go through first as well
as I Creed their guidelines and
understand obviously they have this
whole marketing campaigns and understand
because as we are doing this as well
they were doing their own promotional
inside to like really sit still so we
had to be sure that we were doing like
they felt part of the same world rather
than just completely different things we
did a lot of exploration on this project
we had actually a long design phase for
this so I did a lot of like this is all
of the early studies we did and this is
because it was a very good relation with
Microsoft where we explore different
things before we nailed what they really
wanted and what we wanted so we went
from like this very graphical approach
we're trying like they always had this
idea of the light moving because like
making feel like he's evolving at some
point there was an idea of having each
like the word and all the stuff in a
room environment but that was a bit hard
because there wasn't that much elements
that we could put in the scene to make
it feel like an actual environment and
then we also have this like icons being
laid so there was first it was supposed
to be more like clay can deforming and
instructing with a grade and then he
became just the cubes
kind of coming in and form the local
intelligence as well this was like these
ones were done by twisted poly is this
like website name thing but is he was
doing like we're doing like he's kind of
more like cylindrical shapes and then we
became again the cubes and then more two
different shapes and this came based on
like how they wanted to represent data
through the mix between what Microsoft
wanted and what we were trying to push
for and yeah the live action it was
great as well we tried to do a story bar
so we knew exactly what we needed
because we had so many interaction
points between going from live-action to
3d that we had like a list of shots that
like I need a mouse click I needed
typing on the keyboard all the things
like have like go get on this I could
like on the day I was like check check
right so as we continued on in this
conversation
nidia shared many more explorations that
her and her team exhausted for this
project it was very clear to me that
she's the type of person to explore
every single direction possible so that
they could find the right one I think
it's really important for projects on
this scale and magnitude so that was one
of the first tests we're doing it's like
having these cannons isometric very
clean backdrops but then have maybe it's
more of these glass so this glass panels
they are a part of the design they're
not classic called acrylic so we're
trying to incorporate them so here was
like trying to get this very like clean
look word I'm trying to like other
different the lines coming in showing
how like everything is supposed to align
so this was very early stage and while
we're doing these they're also still
working on the UI so some things end up
changing later on as they were working
in doing user testing did you design all
of these in 3d yes all of this ones are
cinema 4d cinema 4d and what did you use
to render it red shift red shift yeah
these are beautiful here's the airplanes
because at some point we're trying to
play with like metaphors if the email
gets sent and you're in this 3d world
and the airplane would go of keeping it
very like stylized as well so you
wouldn't be like crazy world so this was
very earliest explorations they would
come to the
laptop and when I put this great was to
be like more like the design grace and
then someone that works like it looks
like the tiles in the bathroom I was
like oh that looks so gorgeous and then
once you said that now I can't unsee
that it just looks like bathroom tiles
whether I'm taking it off yeah so this
was for collaboration this one in one of
her early ideas was to have since each
user gets a sign a color at the back
that instead of being like a normal
paper as they are collaborating would be
like this kind of glass ish fluent
design I know that is organic and then
as the person pipes often word is to put
color into this glass and they will
start bleeding into these karadian so
it's like as the collaborate you just
got it's like more and more into this
beautiful gradient so you will start
very simple with one color of one user
and then you start seeing much more calm
splitting out and then will become this
kind of like full paper made of like
these kind of different gradients will
be like different users combining into
this paper document that they're doing
so this is try to be very metaphoric but
obviously the problems that is still
Microsoft and I mean there's not a
problem but they had their own language
so they found that this was a bit too
abstract right which I knew when I was
three to be honest I always like to try
it first right it's better to go further
and exhaust the exploration before you
start editing yourself so early because
you know if you limit your thinking so
early then you know you might not run
into some very interesting ideas that
nobody had thought of so I just wanted
to point it out that this three frame
sequence is very beautiful it has this
nice abstract metaphor of flow and I can
I you know I you know if I'm assigning a
story to it just when I look at these
three frames the way you describe it
makes me feel like there's all these
collaborators and it's all this nice
flowy process and then you reveal it as
this single document that then DePaul
been working on so I love this if I was
your creative director you know somebody
who had to pitch this you'd be making my
job very very easy
yeah it was like obviously like we know
like you said when I was I always think
that you should definitely push it
further when you can at the beginning
because there's no point to anything I
thought because sometimes you may have a
misconception about the client thinking
always not gonna go for this and maybe
they're actually more mine open-minded
than you think
so I did try and obviously they said
they liked it so that's the thing they
liked it but they felt that knowing that
what they've done in the past as well
and making the brand's feel like well
maybe let's not do that so you end up
being like this so because they have the
panel to say hey can we just have the
panel's straight like without being
organic and then maybe they just as each
person collaborates maybe it's a panel
so then we change a bit the story and we
had as we always fought about having one
computer and the other and we thought
that this would be the perfect moment to
transition from one actor to the other
because it's only it's the first time
that they're actually together
collaborating so the idea was like to
have a camera from one side rotating to
the other side to the live-action and in
the middle would be 3d so she'll start
typing you see this movement coming you
know as a panel and then you start
rotating and you were you're kind of
panning for this kind of world of word
collaboration with all these panels
being text and then going back to the
new user now who already seen this girl
typing before the story works really
well so it was like trying to go like
I'm super abstract so it's to kinda has
this are abstract but it does we had put
the text in to make more understandable
because sometimes it's as well like if I
tell this story it's on the other one
it's easier to understand but if people
say it for the first time probably
wouldn't and here it's more clear or
there's texture they're typing and all
this stuff and then the other ones that
we did yeah and this is another one I
have so this this one was as well one of
the ones for collaboration and you was
based on the concept of the color
bleeding and one of the things that the
creative director from Microsoft
asked was to have a symbol per section
so we had a few things that we had to be
like to sho like collaboration
speed and stuff like that so you wanted
to create it like different symbols for
each one we end up taking most of them
out because of the length of the story
but this was the first one that I do one
of the early stages of the
collaborations will be the same with the
color late and then with the light and
the caustic zucchet it's kind of like
blending off the whole gradients oh man
you're speaking my visual language right
here I'm so in love with this though
it's so gorgeous
Thanks one strengths that I see in your
work and the work that you've showed us
so far is that because you work in 3d
because you dabble a little bit here in
live-action you have a strong sense of
lighting you have a strong sense of
design and a strong sense of movement
and all of these things overlap and kind
of add up to each other in terms of
understanding what the final results can
look like so I think over time with
experience of you just being able to go
out there and pick up a lot of different
things working with a lot of different
people it really shows with a project
like this where you get to exercise your
full breadth of skills and knowledge and
apply it across very different mediums
so kudos to you and I love seeing this
work it's amazing yeah I definitely
agree with you like I think the thing
like I've always been like a you know
like a jack of all trades master of none
for save because I like so many
different things but it does help me
when I have to do these things in 3d
like I when I was at hyper I one of my
colors from my my class he was like
really good at photography and filming
so I was like hey how can I become
better at it how can I like you good at
taking pictures it's just telling you
how to buy a camera you can't just read
about it in depth equipment go out there
and try it but now it helps cuz now I
can I know how things work and all crazy
stuff like I mean I don't have a
professional course but I've read a lot
about it I tried I bought different
lenses and so I think that like knowing
a bit of everything I think it comes
really well when you're an hour director
because you'd have to do a different
people and different secretaries right
so it's good to have that basic
understanding of this of what you asking
someone like I should know
that's that's totally right if we all
speak the same language then it's much
easier to communicate and get what you
need done and realize the vision and the
beautiful thing about I think where
industry is headed in terms of motion
design and the tools is that they're
getting so similar to each other with
all of these amazing 3d renderers that
we have out there now obtain redshift
Arnold like all of these and the 3d
packages that are out there they're
pretty much all the same language you
know I mean just like how the cameras
operate how the Lighting's work all of
the the tools and technical aspects of
it are bleeding into each other because
it's all based off of physical stuff
real life stuff so that's awesome that
you got a chance to explore with a
regular camera because I could see I
know also from my experience that that
applies into the 3d world because if you
understand how a real camera works how
real lighting works and it's very easy
to replicate and make something look
good or amazing in 3d yeah that's fair
yeah I think I think yes like I said I
was like ratchet dancing as the software
evolves you became a more real right and
now always tell people like if you're
lighting something how would you do it
in real life branches that you think
that way and trying to go where I'm
gonna put the lights on how we do it
that should help you at least kickstart
something absolutely same thing with
camera moves you know if you want
something to look real you have to make
realistic camera moves otherwise if you
have an ultra-wide lens that's just
flying around you know that feels very
fake versus what's actually possible so
when I like to animate and design stuff
if the objective is to be more realistic
then I think about well where's the
camera man where's the crane where's the
track like how would this operate in
real life so that we can mimic something
in real life and you know that's how you
get this hyper real look or almost
true-to-life
look and I get really premium in this
next project Nydia walk through a
sponsorship opportunity with HP they
commissioned her to create something
under the theme of the power to reinvent
Beauty to help promote their new
hardware now I wanted to say this is a
great example of how creators can work
directly with brands nowadays this goes
to show that if you have a good personal
brand and a presence online
companies will find a way to leverage
your skills your stories to help align
and achieve their own marketing goals so
HP last year was contacting a few
different artists to help them extend
their like tell tell these people in our
industry that hey we do good laptops and
desktop hardware that we want you guys
to be using so they invited me to to be
part of one of those artists to use one
of their machines and do an artwork for
it which is pretty fun so pretty much it
was very open brief and I could do
whatever I want as long as you went
within them a shame that they gave to
all artists just to make sure that we
are doing the same at least have
something in common and the theme was
the power to reinvent beauty so as I was
doing this when I got the brief I was
like this is the final piece and when I
was doing it I was trying to think for
me what is beauty and and I realized
that I mean I definitely thought but
Beauty is very different for different
people but it's really hard to like do
something that to represent Beauty
because everyone has their own standards
of it so then I start thinking about our
industry and all of that and then I
wanted to show how the process is
beautiful like how something gets to a
point because there's a process behind
it so I had a few ideas when one of them
right I call this craftsmanship what I
like how sometimes people forget about
how much goes behind an artwork or
something like that and I do abstract
stuff so he was mixing all the things
that I liked into one piece so this one
I my idea was to have this book that's
falling like that's going from like a
harsh rocky side so the left side and as
he goes to the right to the top it
becomes much more organic so it's trying
to create this process from like harsh
to like like I was trying to play with
contrasts and having like each person
will probably like something more from
one side or the other and trying to get
this and I think for me this was
actually harder to do they
usually when I just tell friends I do
different sovereigns tell a story and
here I only had one image to tell a
story
mm-hmm so he had I had to think in a
different way right he's like it's only
one picture and he has to say something
and obviously I like doing abstract
stuff because it means that people can
take their own spin on it and your own
taken what they feel about it and for me
was like really having this harsh and
organic all combined and having this
kind of progression between one to the
other so I what I did is I took pictures
of crystals Wow
I always liked crystals and I always
liked anything played with nature one of
the requirements was to use a bit of
Adobe software right because there's
this Adobe MAX last year so and I I love
Photoshop so I thought hey I can like
take buy some crystals take pictures and
use them as texture and do like a bit of
butter bashing so I found the store here
in Toronto that sells like crystals so I
bought a few of them with a variety and
then I took pictures to them
nothing fancy was just like a paper
white paper and direct sunlight
I was trying first a photo match
everything in Photoshop and then as I
asked
so I can simply be and I sculpted I
started like pretty much the
craftsmanship right I start with this
block and then I start sculpting parts
of it and then I just render it out into
different materials and then I mix it in
Photoshop what software did you use to
sculpt that is that also cinema 4d
yes very yes I try ZBrush before but
then I just feel so I always keep my
lawyer you know Photoshop afterwards so
great so yeah so I went from like
rendering it and then laying everything
in Photoshop Wow and then I just add
like the photos that I took from the
crystals and at one point I decided to
put these branches and in flowers just
to give it a bit more connection with
nature because it's something I really
like and because I was having these kind
of eyes and rocks and bubbles just all
that was missing like something in there
and so I just keep on adding elements
until the point that I said no oh my
gosh I love this what's super cool about
this is
I know earlier you said I'm a jack of
all trades but master of none
I feel like actually a master of all
when I look at these things and you know
seeing the final result which is
obviously beautiful but you utilize all
of the layered skills that we were
talking about earlier which is
photography 3d Photoshop and learning
how to combine all those things together
where you just do a little bit in each
and the final result you're able to come
up with something very very amazing
because you're able to utilize all those
skills where I feel like some people who
are specialists are kind of stuck in one
particular lane they aren't able to take
something all the way to fruition like
this have us such a beautiful ending
result because people especially who
work in pipelines they might only work
on one part of it and they might not
know how to do the rest of this stuff
but for you being able to take this from
concept all the way to final delivery
and final render and having the result
that you have it's it's a testament to
how good your skills actually are even
though you claim here a master of men in
this next project
nidia shares her experience doing title
design and animation work for the
semi-permanent 2018 festival she played
a small part in a larger collaborative
effort and her approach changed here and
she shares with us how it was different
because this time not only was she
designing something she was also
animating it let's take a look so Joyce
amazing director and designer so she got
the chance to work on directors of a
titles for sweet from the last year and
as part of that year Dropbox was one of
the sponsors so they wanted to make it
about collaboration so when she got into
the project to say hey we wanted to
collaborate artists to create this piece
so just approached me to do one of the
parts on this paper in which I was very
happy it was very different I was really
nice yes I always like to show this or
talk about this project because I just
stills nowadays but I had to animate on
this one which was a good challenge for
myself seeing how my brother feels like
skills and so we were a big team and I
was supposed to be doing act 3
so this was all pacing like microscope
organisms which for me it's like I love
all the stuff so I was like yes what was
the goal of the visuals here what was it
supposed to communicate for this title
sequence because you had a collaboration
right yeah so this one choice has a
better like talking about the whole
direction because that was actually her
her side but she talked about this kind
of creative tension so she wanted to
kind of show that creative tension but
she wanted to the collaboration to be
part of like different artists coming
together to create this one unified
piece and she she did an amazing child
she had already like an animatic by the
time I talked to her so it's like I was
very easily sold on idea she's tough
time pneumatic air by DN a-- so this is
one of the reference that she sent
that's this one and yeah I was like
blown away and I did a bit more
exploration about this and I really
wanted to create these shapes and the
main difference from this project to
others that I've done is that I always
start with tolerance I'm more passionate
about this option to kind of look and
but at this time I had to find a mate so
I was like that crazy normally it's
somebody else's problem because you
could just hand up a crazy style frame
but this time you only have to be
responsible for animating this time I
actually started by the other way around
which is I started by doing testing of
40 I had a basic idea of what I wanted
so then I was just here like a little I
was trying to make my life simple and
snow pretty so he's so this is just most
clients and he made it interesting so
yeah I was like I don't want to break
stuff so I was like how can I make this
organic so I started exploring feels
like it's so merry
oh yeah so I was thinking of the cell
friends as early on as I wished for but
I was doing a lot of motion exploration
like how can I make things and that's
actually having fun but I was trying to
make it more like not super keyframe
because I'm not that good I wish I was
so I was just trying to take my lanes
like right I was like X particles to do
the calls and then I did and then I did
the comping as well so I did the company
but the nice ended to dress because she
was putting everything together
so she then she she made the top layer
on top of it to make sure that all of
them seemed like particles floating and
all that stuff and then this second shot
was actually I wasn't supposed to be
working on this but then she asked me to
help and I just did a quick testing X
particles and obvious because he went
from lying on this final part of my
scene so yeah I had a lot of fun because
it's like trying to go back to oh I was
emotional you coming you you did the
loop around right you came all the way
backgrounds like oh yeah good anime
right that's what I was getting into
it's a hyper island so I just wanted to
point out like the final result looks
again very very impressive but as you
break it down like this
for our audience we might be looking at
this and maybe are not familiar with the
tools or the industry as you can see
like what
nidia has done here is that it's just
broken down these are all tiny little
pieces and she's utilizing things like
procedural animation where you have one
thing that's pretty much animating on
its own based off of either simulations
or noise patterns just black and white
patterns and then it's a lot of just
scale rotate and repeat right so a lot
of it a lot of cleaner there's a lot of
cloners a lot of just duplication and
you know that's very common in the
motion design space it's a very easy way
to make things look very amazing
beautiful and organic just duplicate
scale rotate and offset right look those
are kind of the those are the bread and
butter of the motion design industry
when you enemy something small and fun
just replicating it like this can have
tastic result that we're seeing in this
title sequence here so wow this next
project was for a shoe company called
reserva they hired her to develop a
looping animation around the idea of
comfort let's see what she came up with
this agency was like a loop Instagram
loop every month and made by different
artists so every month would be
different artists and they gave a
different keyword for every artist so
mine was comfort
Jaffar was a comfort at the beginning
but I had more ideas so you have to
represent comfort the idea of comfort
yeah and this shoe had to be there so I
send them a little back they asked for
some ideas what I wanted and I was
trying to think like how can they show
comfort and you were supposed to only be
once she was from the scene and I was
actually traveling at the time I was in
Montreal exploring the city and I saw
this bouncy castle it kids sounds like
Oh what if above the castle because I
felt like it's fun and it's comfortable
like the cruise ship or inflatable so
then I I sent that husband off ideas and
a little mood board and then they they
were specifically wanted an environment
as well so this was part of that please
ask everyone to have some kind of
environment in it so I was just trying
to get some mood part for myself of what
type of the environment that I do as
part of it and as well that would work
for an intimal castle can it me so those
I send this in another idea I went for
this my husband does know a few things
what's in Maya so I was like oh wow in
my surrealist he was trying to figure
out how to make them feel like the
creases and all the stuff that we have
equitable or balloons even so as he was
doing these little tests he sprayed out
for me and I try I was just playing with
like how it should look so I was getting
reference from balloons and inflatable
castles and trying to just nail that
look that I wanted
so I was having fun while he was doing
all the hard work as I was doing that he
was animating the shoe so again you know
hard work send me this issue that was
canned and I was just as well texturing
it with the pictures that they gave me
lighting it making sure that everything
was the same so I was in that parts and
one part of the comfort was we had this
insole we had to show it so making sure
he looked the same so it's doing more
like lighting shading and texturing and
as we were going for this that
environment
I was trying like different colors on it
like I wanted to do this blues and pinks
and we wanted to have like these
reaction so when this shoe would hit the
floor that's when the whole like the
skating would happen so that was like
the reaction points for us to like make
sense and because this was a looping it
to like it's light and then to fight
back again we send this to the client
from the comments like good but I was
like I don't like it
is weird because for the complicated to
have a shoe being big because he had to
have a specific size for like because as
the product but having this kind of
realistic environment but then he felt
so out of proportion I liked it so I
change I change it a lot better that you
approved scrap that say what did they
say when you know sometimes it's a
little nerve-wracking for some clients
have to go along this journey and
they're expecting something and then you
change it what was their reaction when
you showed them this they were fun of it
they were they're actually like the I
explain us why I changed I just didn't
say hey you stop I explained saying
either even if I did like some of the
qualities of the other image it was
wrong we felt along the scale so I
wanted to make it more like feel like it
was kind of a right to scale and this
way also got more light into it just the
other one I only had one window per se
here I could have much more
environmental into it in the sky and
stuff like that so they said oh good
that's like ok ok guys wish it was like
that
I say yes a listing also I was building
this and texturing it on all the stuff
and my husband was then making sure that
this new environment would back into it
so he was just and this was before
timing star we're doing we're just
checking the timings and if everything
worked and look correctly it's just a
fine one wow that's so awesome yeah so
[Music]
again kudos for my husband hard work so
did he have to simulate all of that
stuff he inflated it yes all the columns
they are the same I think everything
that is similar we we use it the stairs
for example these stairs here we we use
them here in terms of the simulation so
anything that was very similar we were
purposes otherwise would just be would
always have to get like his Olympic
files to me and then I would buy like
shading and making sure everything and
rendering and all of that but yeah I had
fun I love working with my husband and
so that it was a fun project to do as a
collaboration yeah but did he have fun
with it though yeah he liked it he's the
Rico but he likes and Clark and Maya so
and so I'm like I mean that's it sounds
like you found a really good partner
both in life and as a creative
professional because you know some
people really geek out about that stuff
some very technical stuff I love
partnering with those people too and I
work on projects and I'm creative
directing I love bringing on these very
technical people because I feel like
they fill in a gap in my brain that I
don't have in terms of how to think or
solve something right like I have some
kind of vision to figure out of course
it's really wild and crazy and maybe I
could take it like sixty percent there
with the tools and skills that I have
but I always need to hire somebody who's
exceptionally good at what they do
whether that be you know simulation or
particles or whatever this is you know
it's
not very often that I meet a
jack-of-all-trades who's actually really
talented at whatever she sinks her teeth
into
I found Nydia to be a creative whose
insatiably curious very hard-working yet
humble at her core you know if you had
one bit of advice for a young designer
who sees your work and just wants to
develop a great portfolio like you is
there any advice that you would give to
our audience yeah I think it's like some
are very straightforward which is work
hard stay humble I think they're very
important stay humble in our industry
and for me it's just everything flow
naturally like I I always had like goals
to achieve and once I got to them I
found another one so I think you just
keep doing there like keep finding
someone that you like and try reaching
to their level and but on your own take
and then just keep on finding someone
else me that you like and and just keep
on like pushing yourself because the
front part is going looking back and
seeing how much we involved and I always
like to say that obviously like I've
been Indians for like nine years so it's
a first one they start in like you know
I didn't start like this
so I didn't start out of like it's like
I thought it was cool and I look back
and you're terrible so it always going
to evolve and you're always going to
realize that's what you're doing the
past yeah I think that reminds me of my
high school art teacher one thing that
she told us the class all the time
whenever we were like rendering our
sketches or anything like that she
always said an artist is never finished
and you know that sticks with me today
like 20 years later I still think about
that an artist or a creative is never
finished and it's this constant process
of evolution and growth and constantly
challenging yourself so I'm glad you
kind of share that perspective and I
wish that everybody would would pick
that up because there's no end of the
road it's all part of the journey and
you want to constantly grow otherwise
you'll get really bored and the life
would be very boring cool well I don't
want to take up too much of your time
anymore so as we
wrap this where's the best place for
people to go find you oh my website is
needed is calm and my handle is yes I am
NOT I am alright well thank you so much
for spending your time your afternoon
with with me today your evening or
morning wherever you're at right now
thank you so much for giving us your
time and yeah I hope to see you continue
to grow in flourish and want to check in
with you a couple years a couple months
from now because I'm sure you're gonna
be making amazing work thanks and thanks
for inviting me I had really great fun I
hope you enjoyed this conversation with
Nidhi ideas if you have any questions
about working in the motion design
industry leave us a comment below and
we'll do our best to answer it if you
want to learn more about the art of
creating beautiful style frames consider
taking my course where I teach you my
process of designing dynamic images to
tell powerful stories I'll leave a link
in the description below that's it for
us don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe we'll see you in the future